hi I'm Chris Aneesa I'm a mathematician
at Queens College of the City University
of New York I'm going to be talking
about data mining imaginary maps where
this is a collaboration with Emily
Garfield who was an artist in New York
City she makes amazing cellular artwork
that we're going to be analyzing and
investigating
hello everybody so my name is Kristen
Issa I am I am at Queens College of the
City University of New York and I'm
gonna be talking to you about a project
that I did as a collaboration with an
artist who Emily Garfield who's in New
York City so let's do with what we have
okay so let me share with you so let me
show you a picture of something amazing
that Emily draws so she makes these
amazing map like objects where they are
built using using an algorithm in her
head you would have seen a picture of
her watercolors these are watercolor
made objects she first draws the regions
and then fills them in she draws the
regions algorithmically with and with
the algorithm in her head and then fills
them in with the colors that she feels
like they should be there right this is
a purely artistic method of creating
beautiful beautiful works of art so one
of the things that that we'd like to
know is what so so Emily came to me and
said hey this is an interesting thing to
do she was always interested in learning
more about her work so questions that
came up to hers oh so these are these
these maps that she makes they are not
actual places it's not like there's a
place that she's thinking about when
she's drawing these but the question is
well what makes them look like maps
everybody sees that and says that looks
like a map and then if you have this map
what would life be like if you were
there if you were to living in that in
that block what would life be there like
there another thing is that she was
really interested about there's there's
a the work of Jackson Pollock there's
been academic work trying to learn about
the fractal nature of his prints
and there's there's various so so is
there some fractal nature of Emily's
work
there's also amazing data visualization
of cities here
what you would see here is you would see
a map of New York and then a map of New
York sorted by blocks so block size
block shape and then laid out in a
beautiful visualization
similarly Jeff Boeing's work takes a map
of a city and then figures out the
orientations of the edges based on the
the directions and the orientations of
the of the roads ok so the motivation is
Ken Lee is so so let's what can we learn
about the questions so these are the
questions I wanted to ask can we
quantify Emily's Maps can we learn
things about the maps can we learn
things about the color palette that she
uses in her pictures what can we learn
about the structure of the blocks and of
the roads can we analyze the neighbors
of blocks what type of fractal qualities
are there and can we come up with an
algorithm to create maps that look like
Emily's Maps and so the overarching
question is well what really makes a map
a map that's that's our investigation
okay so mmm it's also a huge file it's
250 megabytes so that may be paying into
this too so here's a black and white
version of a map hopefully it later on
we'll see what the map looks like but I
needed to take this colorful map and
import it into Mathematica so how do I
do that first I tried so what what I
wanted to do is take each of the cells
and understand each of the cells
individually so in order to do that I
needed to make a black and white version
of this map so I wanted to do that
algorithmically I tried a number of
different things binarize I've also used
morphological binarized but whatever I
did it was never perfect so I needed to
get em
to come in and do some manual cleaning
of the final version that I had once you
get a final version of it then you can
use image mesh to take it out and get
each of the the blocks that are in the
in the picture
and then we can take the components and
then this would be one of the blocks
that we're going to to look at and then
from that we can use a mask and get a
mask of each of the pieces so these are
what each of the individual pieces would
look like of this and then what we can
do is we can average the not so one of
the things is that this mask on a really
large picture the mask doesn't you need
to a smaller mass for it to actually
process in a reasonable amount of time
so I made a smaller rectangle of each of
the sizes of the blocks and then I
averaged over the over the the non-white
parts of this rectangle and you can see
that I can extract the color from each
of the each of the blocks so once you do
that oh look a map okay so this is one
of Emily's pictures and then this is the
what mathematica will see after I've
done the transformation which taken each
of these blocks and given them the right
size in the right shape and now they
have the average color of each of the
regions so that that I can do for almost
any map or any mat any map any picture
that she gives I can do that
but if I'd like to learn more about the
road network that is intensive in many
many many different ways it's
computationally intensive it's also
human labor intensive so I used skeleton
transform pruning thinning and binarize
encoder tan whip and made them now one
one pixel wide roads and then you can
still see maybe you can see maybe you
can't there's little artifacts on here
that have to be gotten rid of so
we found that the best way to do that is
just to do some more manual cleaning you
have to also get rid of all the little
artifacts that are on the edges and then
you can apply morphological graph and
then you get a graph okay but again this
graph isn't perfect because there's
little junctions there's little vertices
in on these edges there's also like
maybe there's multiple vertices that
really should just be one vertex
corresponding to a neighborhood so I had
to do some manual cleaning of that I had
the coalesce vertices I had to remove
the non connected parts removed the
degree two vertices and then in the end
every vertex has degree 1 or 3 I then
added some corner vertices to make the
boundary faces and did some more final
manual cleaning and then that gives us
the structure of this of the of the the
road network and then if we want the
structure of the block network we need
the dual graph and so we find the dual
graph of the the graph and we need to
put it where the vertices are on each of
the face centroids and so after dealing
with that you now have both the road
network and you have the the block
Network and so you now have two
different things you have the components
any of the centroids of the components
and then you have the block neck and
block Network where you had vertices
that came from the faces and so you had
to then align the two and then after all
that you finally get a picture where you
have every component you have it
numbered and you know exactly which
vertex it is in the graph and then you
can do some analysis so that's a lot of
stuff just to get it into a right format
and there was a lot of manual parts so
really you can't do the most the biggest
maps that she has to you can't analyze
those but the smaller ones you can
analyze all right so the first thing I
want to talk about is color analysis so
often people think about RGB how much
red how much blue how much green there
is in a in a color
I liked thinking about it more in terms
of else
H so lightness chroma and hue so you
have some amount of how bright it is or
how saturated is and what hue the the
color is so for each of the maps you can
create one dimensional plots of the
color distribution so of that green map
you have this is the distribution of the
colors in terms of lightness terms of
chroma in terms of hue but it gets more
interesting when you add more put the
dimensions together so here is a picture
where I've taken each of the the
region's each of the blocks and then
laid it out in terms of chroma and hue
so that you get more you can see a
little bit more of the structure of the
color the color field
here's hue versus lightness and here's
lightness versus chroma but really the
best thing to do is to go into one more
dimension which is to look in terms of
this is these are all of the different
blocks and all the different colors you
can see the distribution of the colors
from the from the from the map based and
each of the circles represents the area
of of it so you get a you get a strong
idea about the structure of the the
color distribution in the map so here
I'm going to show you three more of them
well I'm going to show you three more
color distributions without the maps but
you can see here's here's this was you
can see you can imagine it's mostly a
red map right
whereas here's two other ones these are
more more colored maps or many variety
of colors but what I hope you can see
here is there's a structure to the
colors that are used right I sort of
feel like there's a mountain right there
for each of the dominant colors there
seems to be like a mountain of the
colors that are in the blocks right and
I feel like what that means is that if
you want a fingerprint of emily's color
schemes then you have this mountain
quality to the colors that are present
in
the pictures alright so since I'm here
here's a picture of Emily this is what
Emily looks like and so here so here
okay here we are so here is here's a
picture of this map and this this here's
the 3d version of that map and then
here's another one of these pictures and
that's these are the these are the two
dimensional and then three dimensional
versions of the color schemes so let's
go into some of the other types of
analysis that you can do so we can also
look at the blocks individually we can
ask the question about the size of the
blocks we can ask a question about the
density of a block so if we take a block
and we do with three times the size how
much of that area is taken up by other
blocks we can talk about how rectangular
a block is and so let's say you wanted
to look at the block size so here are
six different pictures and for the six
different pictures this is a histogram
of the blocks out the sizes of the
blocks that there are so if you take the
log if you instead of looking at the
size we look at the log of the size you
can actually see a pretty striking
similarity in terms of the block sizes
that appear in the maps they seem pretty
normal so I thought that was an
interesting takeaway from from the the
set up one thing I'm pretty proud of is
that you can see the color schemes of
these maps these are extracted from the
the maps themselves by clustering the
colors and then based on the cluster and
the uuughh cluster in terms of a certain
number of things and based on those
colors you then extract the the that the
the average color for that cluster and
you assign it a weight based on the area
of the map that's covered by that
cluster and then and then this is
basically here are the main colors that
appear
in the picture sorted by the area that
they cover in the map and let me skip a
couple of those we can also talk about
the road analysis so we can talk about
the width of the roads we can talk about
the length of the roads the distance
between the intersections and we can
talk about the orientation so this
matter this work by Jeff Boeing had
pictures of cities and then the the
classic the the the basically a circular
histogram of the of the the density of
the direction of the roads and I was
able to replicate that in Mathematica
and so what do you do you take your you
can see in this map most of the roads
that go this direction are kind of
bending downwards which you can see also
in this histogram this histogram
represents the street orientations so
it's saying most of the roads go this
way there's a good chunk that goes this
way but there's not many roads that go
this way or this way what's that right
so if it's a square grid right if it's a
square core so so let me I'll be back in
a second but here this picture is much
more bubbly and in this there's not
really a direction that's more more
there than others and so you can see
that the histogram is basically a circle
because the directions of the roads are
rather rather uniformly distributed so
here's four different for different of
these visualizations here's one more so
in terms of the real world in terms of
the real world
normally Road the especially in of the
state's roads are put on grids so here's
a picture of a commission that Emily did
in in about a town in Massachusetts and
there you can really start to see the
grid nature and that's shown in these in
the in the visualization because most
roads lie on those perpendicular axes
all right so we can ask things about the
number of neighbors the neighbor size
ratio so how different are two blocks
that our neighbors have different other
colors I'm gonna skip those because I
think people are more interested maybe
in terms of fractal analysis so if we
wanted to talk about what would what
would fractal what would it mean for one
of Emily's maps to be fractal well I
think the best way to think about it is
that the sub images would look a lot
like the big images so the neighborhoods
around small blocks do they look like
neighborhoods around large blocks and so
in order to do that we can compute the
quintiles of the block sizes so we can
break down the blocks into being the
smaller blocks the medium blocks and the
largest blocks and see if we can compare
those sets and see if the the the
pictures behave similarly for the small
ones the medium ones and the large ones
and so for example if we wanted to look
at the color distributions so quintile
one the smallest the medium and the
largest if I look at this just like from
far away they all kind of look the same
I mean there's a little bit of
difference maybe in this picture and
maybe a little bit here but in general
it feels like the colors don't actually
depend on the block size for the so
that's one thing that's independent one
thing that's that's dependent is that
the larger the block is the more
neighboring blocks there are that's to
be expected if you have a large block
there's more things around it and the
larger the block the wider the road is
so given a block that's a larger block
you have a larger road surrounding it
although it didn't actually behave
exactly the way I thought it would
behave so let's talk about creating a
new map so I use Mathematica to generate
some new imaginary maps and so in order
to do that I generated random block
positions I found
some block boundaries and so I used for
annoy in de l'année triangulations and
then I did a double duel so I used a
dual graph and another dual graph and I
know that's going to give you back the
same thing but what what I really did is
I changed the position so that it had a
nicer layout and so I did it twice and
what I get is I get this this region
which starts to look a little bit blocky
right different sizes I then took these
polygons and I rounded each of the
polygons I added a little bit of space
in between them and then I colored them
using the distribution of colors that I
found from we learned about earlier
which is that there's there's going to
be some major colors and they'll be will
take will sample colors from a
distribution that has a nice mountainous
feel to them and will prioritize colors
based on proximity so all of the grayish
ones are over here and then the purplish
ones are here and when I do that a
couple of times I came up with some
pieces of art so if I chose vertices the
Liberty deliberately you get this type
of stress ting graph structures if I
chose random vertices I get this more
nature organic feel to them and so what
are the takeaways from our project well
I would say that yes we can quantify her
maps there are certain defining
characteristic Eric turistic that there
are in the maps I wouldn't say that
they're fractal it's a little
disappointing to her and me but I think
it's I think it was interesting to try
to come up with some of these metrics
that we could investigate I
I'm not just a mathematician I am also a
mathematical artist so it's a lot of fun
to make these new maps choosing points
is a hard thing to do or choosing where
you want your blocks and I love
generative art also
so Emily's takeaways were that it was
really fascinating to see a statistical
analysis of her
it makes her think about her art a
little bit differently which you know if
you go into if you if he is that going
to change the way she makes art in the
future well she'll probably be informed
a little bit by what we were talking
about the art was more random than she
expected she she was going in and
thinking I'm doing this very
algorithmically but when you look at
some of these things there's more
randomness than she expected in terms of
the process and then the paper and then
the humidity and then the the all the
the tools that she was using and a
philosophical question is when you do
this with a piece of art and you learn
about it from a quantitative point of
view are you really taking the art out
of the art right this is now super
numerical and it's not artistic or is it
is this just a different layer or what
what's happening there so this is a
philosophical question there's lots of
things that we'd like to learn more
about but what I can say is if you're
interested in seeing these slides as you
saw you can go to my website and
download these slides and if you're
interested in seeing me as a an artist I
have my art portfolio here you can
follow me online I have a mathematical
jewelry business that I've used that
I've created using Mathematica and I
will be having a lunch roundtable for
people interested in talking about art
and jewelry at lunch tomorrow this is
Emily's information and I'll do one
final shout out to the sayara initiative
which is a group of people who are
interested in both science and art and
the spectrum in between those two and
that's where Emily and I met and it's a
really nice community so thank you very
much
you